Los Angeles Chargers quarterback back
here on the show Phillip Rivers how are
you Phillip hey what's going on good I'm
fine so uh do you catch a Monday night
game like last night do you tune into
something like that or the Sunday night
game if you're able to catch something
like that oh yeah oh yeah yeah heck of a
game
psycho game both of them both night
games so what do you think of when you
see a final drive like the one that
Rodgers put on how do you take something
Lauzon yeah - all in 2002 she really
three three big big throws and a big run
that was a heck of a drive I mean even I
think he said it he was thinking so
Collier backed up 45 seconds left in no
timeouts but yeah made some unbelievable
throws you know and then you know shoot
I was a little surprised with the with
the defense there in those last few
plays but he obviously took advantage of
opportunities a couple back shoulders
those hot straight balls he's the best
that could get him out of bounds and get
down there for game where yeah walk me
through what a mindset you have to have
does is it a different than obviously in
the first 50 some odd minutes of a game
when you're stepping out there game on
the line what is your mindset when you
stroll on feel in a situation like that
fella yeah I think so it certainly
depends what it is are you down do you
need three do you need seven do any
timeouts all those things obviously
situational you got to be aware of it
and and that plays into a little bit of
whether you're a little more
conservative little more aggressive
knowing what you can and can't do taking
the canticle sag all those things but he
obviously knew was 16 seconds see it had
to get the ball out of bounds or if it
wasn't bounce that was probably their
last ball that could be played in bounds
and then clock it is gonna gonna be a 40
you know 45 46 yard field goal if they
were tackled in bounds on a 16 second
play but then they gotta bounce on that
one and then got out of bounds on the
other one so that the second one right
by the last one I first vocal they
obviously would not have probably had
time to clock it as I was it I was a
little caught off guard there work in a
little more but defend the sideline
defense on that last play but two great
throws and and heck of a finish
what are you running it yourself I mean
essentially you're getting plays in your
headset maybe but a
essentially the offensive coordinator
when when you're like sixty Seconds
clock taken down
well I mean I I've seen I'm sure
different places do it different ways no
you're getting it you're getting you're
getting the call but you obviously got
to operate it I mean I think it's a
again we're an extension from the
sidelines but you know you know is in
our in our case was as confidence but if
I see something or get to something else
that it's it's us doing it it's not me
going rogue on him you know so but ya
know usually getting stuff inside line
but then you're gonna roll fast off or
something
I see you're I'm sure any of those guys
talking about down the stretch Brady and
Rogers those guys say they get to it on
their own I'm sure Phillip Rivers here
on the Rich Eisen show you're off to an
incredible start Phillip is there
anything different you're doing anything
different what what what to what do you
owe the incredible start that you are
off to this year no I mean I gosh I I
I'm contradicting myself a little bit
because I always say I don't feel like
one year carries over to the next but in
this case I felt like we've been in a
lot of ways we've picked up where we
finished the season you know last year
when it nine of our last twelve and
playing pretty well offensively as a
whole I mean just so balanced and then
we've you know whoever you haven't been
great at times this year obviously you
lose you lose two games but we've been
we've just been consistent we're so
balanced right now I run past and and
we're fishing in the runs just giving us
some opportunity simple aksenchuk plays
down the field the pass game and and
we're taking care of the ball we're
doing all those things that we we've
done we've done over the last 13 years
in different spans weren't as good maybe
the last handful but but been good
really the last the most part the last
15 games and hopefully we can keep this
thing keep this thing rolling this is a
big game this week chance to get to five
and two for the bye get some guys hild
up that are they're a little banged up
and maybe get maybe get one particular
defender back on defense yes well it the
word is that that Joey Bosa is set to
set to join you in the first game in
November is that your understanding
right now
I don't know exactly I just know he's
doing well I know that I know it's nice
to see a cast come off boots come off
and good things like you know is
trending in the right direction but I
tell you what our teeth that's not a
heck of a job in his absent guys in his
essence guys stepping up and gosh these
last couple weeks it's really been it's
really been good for our team but not
speaking up Joey's entry I'm just
speaking of how we want these last weeks
it's been every phase contributed in so
many ways and I think that does a lot
for our team seeing how many guys are
playing a part in us went in the game
that's huge for us as we move through
the you know middle stretch this season
Philip Rivers here on the Rich Eisen
show and you're heading over to London
later on this week business trip right
business trip Philip correct question
she would yeah we're gonna get in there
Friday morning okay family's not come
anymore no no we're gonna get into
Friday morning pet today get settled in
and go straight to the practice still so
yeah we truly uh won't be like site sink
or only just fine last time last time
we're on this East Coast to London trip
we went over to so we've already are off
to a better start so we'll see if we can
if we can make it to another stuff is it
true though that you are sightseeing in
Cleveland is that is that a fact Philip
I begun began a preparation on Tennessee
and and it's kind of been just a regular
Tuesday other than not being at home and
so it's yeah it's uh not a lot going on
it is a pretty day here in Cleveland
trying to crisp crisp clear day about
fifty degrees outside yet okay it looks
pretty if we keep going on you might
give me the traffic to I was just kind
of bringing up Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame would you are you going there no I
I can I can keeping my same routine
there's the only thing I'm really
missing right now is I missed has taken
bin dropping off at school and then
enjoyed some family time on this Tuesday
but other than that kind of kind of
doing the same thing I'm gonna get in
the sauna here a little bit I got some
Tennessee film going and it's it's been
a restful restful Tuesday okay
sonna and tennessee titan film so uh
help me out here Phillip okay cuz I've
got three kids ten seven and five how do
I get them to listen can you help me out
here with this you have eight correct am
I correct on that how do you get them to
listen fella I don't know I don't know
that kid I don't know if there's a
manual out on that sometimes they do and
sometimes they don't
I think that's just the way it goes but
yeah so do you I mean do you are you
calm in the face of that pressure yeah
usually you know usually and I think
every every child is different you know
some some some some of ours are right
away the first time they hear it others
it's about four times and some literally
have to say look at me do you hear I'm
saying it's okay
it's yeah there's no I know there's so
many bangles books out I think I found
early on everybody's different and that
everybody's Wayne works a little
different every child's different and
then they're all awesome in their own
way sure do you have dinner together is
it really like a a ten spot a ten top
for you and oh yeah well yeah we try to
sit down together as often as we can I
would say on a normal week for sure
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday we sit down
all together for sure long week and
really even Friday on a home game and
then kind of Sunday nights it's casual I
mean we're all together but we after
hopefully after a win on Sunday night
home game we gonna do ball game food as
we call it whether there's picking wings
or whatever there is playing the ball
game can I do the same thing on my knee
baby grill a burger but it's a little
more casual or just I'm gonna eat as you
please but yeah and they stay see they
stay seated they don't get up they don't
go around I mean like to me I can't I
just I'm half I'm half that size I got a
table for five and it's it's crazy
Philip I don't know how to do I dunno
how to do it but I'm trying I'm trying
to glean some form of information from
you here Ford for four and to a little
more lenient as far as this sitting and
moving around you know okay
because if they were to run off from the
table it's a little there's a little
more less gain I think at the tables
okay not always that that bad of a thing
but yeah I'd say for the most part we're
all ten right there for good 20 minutes
that's a good that's good catch it up on
school and talking and then obviously
the clean up is the real real challenge
we have a lot of helping hands so the
clean up can go fast that's where my
coach comes out I like guys let's go we
all chip in we clean this kitchen eight
minutes come on okay we go and we get it
done so those are those are the times
that those are awesome times I look
forward to those those those evenings
yeah dinnertime me too me too I don't
know they I have a different adjective
that leaps to mind but God you know
bless it Phillip that's impressive I'm
learning from you right now plus it
might also help from what we heard from
shawn merriman a couple weeks ago that
you don't curse is that a true story you
do not you do not curse story yeah
that's true story nothing ever comes
close to slipping out ever no I mean III
I don't want to stand here body and say
never but no I
ya know I don't I just not part of my
vocabulary just a lot of lot of dad
governments and shoots and cuz we see
you in the field Phillip and a lot of
people are just assuming you're working
blue out there powder-blue whatever all
or blue you want to work I mean it's
that's what people are assuming they're
wrong no I know yeah oh yeah yeah that's
one thing I can't say you can you can
have me backed up for three and a half
hours out there you don't have to be
anything else
Wow okay fantastic okay so you're
heading over to to London like I said to
you you've got that big game last time
you were there last one for year Phillip
you took on drew brees who just set that
record for most passing yards of all
time I'm wondering what you think of
when you see somebody do it for as long
as he has he's about three he's got
about three years on you what did you
think about when he set that record it
was awesome I mean I we were tuned in
with a volume up I mean I want to make
sure I saw it it was it was awesome
seeing obviously that the
the numbers are going to continue to
creep higher he's playing he's still
claimed super well and uh you know I
think it was obviously talented and
smart and all those all those attributes
he has that we know of but I think maybe
more anything it is show it shows it
showed to me just over the long haul off
his career his belief in itself you know
I mean from the early years here in San
Diego before I got here I got here then
he stinking took off and and got the
guy's career really going and then he
has a terrible shoulder injury that many
thought maybe never play again
and then what he's done in New Orleans
over thirteen years I'm super ball and
so many unbelievable years down there
and then still going so it was uh it was
fun to watch
yeah it's amazing and then you know you
been in Eli that that class of 2004 how
much longer you know cuz we're seeing
Eli struggle right now obviously Big Ben
has his own situation but how much
longer do you think you've got left I I
think I got a handful I think I handful
years ago have some that I don't want to
ever put a hard card number on it I'm
not gonna just play and play and play
and play and play until in and and
finished that way hanging on but at the
same time and no hurry to go I still
couldn't wait to get going
you know yesterday I spend on Tennessee
and today I might enjoy all the prep and
that part of it and and really in it I'm
enjoying this team we have a neat group
of guys from veteran guys all the way
down to the young players and I'm
enjoying it so you don't want to be
anytime soon but at the same time I
think I said this this offseason I don't
think you know we're not here guys
throwing around 45 and that's us you
don't have to worry about that I'm not
doing that
I got a handful well gates can't quit
you gates crank which I know that the
gates is always about you can't quit you
appreciate you rolling onto the show
again
good luck overseas and then we'll chat
down the line second half of the season
I rich enjoyed it thank you see me you
that's Philip Rivers the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience